il a brillé sur les dunes d'arabie
saoudite en janvier dernier jean pierre
garcin est l'un des meilleurs copilotes
sur le rallye dakar
cet habitant de montesson est arrivé
onzième position avec son coéquipier
christian lavieille mon objectif c'était
de faire 10 d'honda karl on a fini 11e
voilà on est pendant longtemps été 10e
et puis on s'est fait rattraper par un
pilote très connue c'est cyril després
un ancien vainqueur moto et c'était pas
grave parce que les moyens n'étaient pas
engagés n'était pas du tout les mêmes
voilà donc on était plutôt satisfait de
la course comme jean-pierre la guerre
sainte les courses automobiles cette
histoire commence dès l'enfance
passionné de voitures et de motos
le sportif grandi avec un père garagiste
un oncle pilotes
il commence à faire des compétitions en
amateur à 25 ans avant de se spécialiser
dans les 4 4 me monter ce n'est dispute
son premier dakar en 1996 en tant que
copilote
un rôle qu'il ne quittera plus pour être
pilote voire du talent voilà et moi je
me suis amusé pendant longtemps à faire
des courses de voitures en amateur mais
j'avais surtout pas le talent alors je
peux on peut tous les tous les pilotes
peuvent faire le dakar c'est qu'une
question d'argent mais après pour un
roulé un rythme élevé et où faut avoir
du talent voilà et donc là je n'ai pas
donc ça m'a jamais effleuré l'esprit
aujourd'hui à 58 ans jean pierre garcin
disputé 22 dakar dans sa carrière une
expérience précieuse dans la navigation
mon rôle c'est lui donner le maximum
d'informations le plus précis possible
dans la voiture à un moment donné elle
l'expérience joue beaucoup quoi presque
le désert partout dans le monde il elle
même en chine en arabie saoudite en
afrique en australie le désert ça
revient toujours la même chose la
connaissance du terrain elle est très
importante quoi savoir ce que le visuel
ça parce qu'on va rencontrer
c'est ce primordial cette histoire
d'amour entre jean pierre garcin et le
dakar n'est pas prêt de se terminer
libinois pense déjà à repartir l'année
prochaine
le jour où tu en as plus en vite il va
plus voilà ça c'est clair franchement
c'est de cette année ç'a tellement été
agréable que je me vois pas ne pas y
aller on pense déjà
comment va y aller ça c'est vrai il
espère cette fois-ci finir dans le top
10 cinq dernières objectif avant de
terminer sa carrière à 60 ans